لا تمر ليله على سكان الضفه الغربيه دون
مشاهد اقتحامات ومداهمات للمنازل بشكل
متكرر منزل جديد هنا في بيتونيا غرب رام
الله اقتحمته قوات الاحتلال فجرت الباب
على اهله اثناء نومهم وقامت بمهمه المنزل
وتركته على هذا الحال الذي سنراه وهو مشهد
متكرر في منازل الفلسطينيين في الضفه
الغربيه من شمالها الى جنوبها في اقتحامات
متتاليه
لمنازل الفلسطينيين تقوم قوات الاحتلال
عند اقتحامها بتخريب المنزل على هذا النحو
وتعيث فيه خرابا وتقوم بالبحث عن ما تصفه
ب
اشياء تتهم سكانه بوجودها في المنزل ولكن
كما يقول سكان هذا المنزل انها قامت
باقتحام المنزل اكثر من سته مرات ولم تعثر
على شيء في هذا المنزل وقامت
باقتحامه مره تلو الاخرى قبل ان تعتقل
صاحب هذا المنزل من هذا المكان ولكن
اللافت انها قامت كذلك باعتداء على سكان
المنزل على
زوجه الشاب المعتقل من هذا المنزل وعلى
اطفاله وكما تشاهدون تركت غرفه الاطفال
على هذا النحو بهذا الخراب الكب كبير وهو
مشهد ايضا من بين المشاهد التي تحدثت عنها
هذه العائله هنا عائله حبوب كما العائلات
مختلفه من سكان الضفه الغربيه التي عاشت
اكثر من
6330 حاله اعتقال فقط منذ السابع من
اكتوبر وما زال هذا السيناريو يتكرر في كل
ليله حسن مسعود الجزيره بتونيا غرب رام
الله n